Can you explain RSO? So when you look up RSO, I don't know if you can see it on Google anymore, you might have to go to an alternate platform RSOs for as far as cancer therapy goes stands for Rick Simpson Oil. Rick Simpson Oil is a high grade THC, which is the psychoactive part of the marijuana plant or the hemp plant that is
the psychoactive component of that is the THC. Concentrated super concentrated THC is what's called Rick Simpson Oil and it comes in a syringe because it's literally the consistency of a black tar.
And it has been shown to be effective in helping kill cancer cells taken at the right dosage.
And the right dosage is measured in what's called grains of rice. That one is equal to one gram, I believe, per day, but it's three grains of rice three times a day.
Now that is a tough THC to knock anybody out and to make you really, really super loopy that does not make you feel good while you're doing the Rick Simpson protocol. It's a three-month protocol.
Once you get up to that dosage and I have not no I have not known anyone that has enjoyed it. It just completely wipes you out. You can't really function during the day.
But it was a protocol that was very big a number of years ago until the FDA came up against anybody that had anything about Rick Simpson Oil on their website, which they came after Austin such as well.
We had to pull anything that was CBD or THC related off of our website.
And even about CBD, even though it has zero psychoactive residue in it, most scrubbed CBD.
Most supplement companies are staying away from making it a matter of fact number of supplement companies that used to make it have stopped making it and stopped selling it.
Because even though ironically how it's THC marijuana is more as getting state licensure across the United States and it's not illegal basically to sell it anywhere instead of having to get it in the black market.
The FDA is even coming down on any company scrutinizing any company much more closely if they're selling even CBD products.
So companies like designs for health and zybage and things that were big name supplement companies have discontinued all their CBD products because they got threatened by the FDA or what that they were going to you know everything else is going to be scrutinized even tighter they've they've all pulled all their products.
It's really kind of sad how the drug industry is controlling everything.
So rick Simpson oil is a very, very concentrated THC component of the marijuana plant can't use heavy activities marijuana to produce it.
It's like a black tarry paste you take it orally usually some people have put it in capsules and used it as a suppository but you're getting less benefit from it.
But the downside is is that is what it makes you feel most people cannot tolerate the protocol.